hello there guys we've officially gotten
our first look at the long anticipated
series the book of boba fett now let's
get straight into the breakdown of
what's being revealed so for this newly
released poster which you can see here
we've been given some insights into new
details on what boba fett will look like
and some cool fun little details let's
just get straight into that so the first
detail here is on the throne you're
sitting on which i presume is the throne
on tatooine inside of jabba's palace you
can actually see um some rancor heads
here on the left and right side of the
chair but the main details i want to
speak about is actually boba fett's new
look now you're probably thinking that
face valley looks pretty much the same
to what we saw in our man law in season
two and for the most part you would be
right but there's actually been some
small changes the first detail is that
it looks like his flight boots are a
little bit different it looks like it's
a bit of a like a brownish red color so
perhaps he's changed his boots for some
reason another change is he actually got
rid of like the the dress cape design
i'm gonna say i'm actually a fan of this
change it looks a lot better although
there is another change which i'm not
sure about it looks like he's removed
the scarf but you know before i thought
the scarf looks pretty sick but you know
that looks like it's removed now perhaps
it's tucked away and we can't see it it
also looks like he's actually changed
his belt as well so you know overall
he's made some small little changes to
his overall look but the biggest change
is that actually his whole entire outfit
is looking a lot more worn you know it's
not looking smooth or as clean as it was
before you can see some scratches and
wear and tear on his armor so you know
he's had some combat he's you know had
some action you know that links me back
to a quote from one of the directors
they said this series is going to be all
killer no filler and it's going to be
you know dark and brutal and boba fett's
just gonna go on a rampage essentially
so i'm really looking forward to you
know what action we can see boba fett do
because apparently it over delivers so
you know my expectations are quite high
i'm excited i should also mention
there's been like a description of the
show released so i'll read that out for
you guys now a thrilling star wars
adventure finds legendary bounty hunter
boba fett and mercenary fennec shawn
navigating the galaxy's underworld when
they return to the sand of tatooine to
stake their claim on the territory once
ruled by jupiter hut and his crime
senecan now this is sound pretty sweet
i'm excited to see what they're going to
do will boba fett expand his crew will
he get more people to join will he fight
against other iconic bounty hunters such
as bosk or potentially bull boss join
his team anyway that's about it for this
video so i hope you enjoyed this
breakdown of the first look at the book
of boba fett do you like the look of his
new armor are you excited for the show
let me know in the comment section below
and also like and subscribe so you don't
miss future content thanks for watching
guys
[Music]
you